[Musica]
la felicità è la mia forza
per me la cosa più importante è essere
felice e tutto il resto viene di
conseguenza
sono arrivata in italia nel 2005 con
mamma papà e le mie due sorelle
mi sono subito iscritta a scuola alle
scuole medie
come tutte le ragazzine della metà la
scuola per me non era soltanto un luogo
di istruzione ma anche il mio primo
approccio con l'atletica e in
particolare quelle corse campestre
dopo cinque anni in italia grazie alla
mamma ci siamo regolarizzati in italia
e così la mamma ha deciso di riportarci
a trovare i nonni una vacanza una
vacanza di svago divertimento invece
quella vacanza si è trasformata nella
programmazione della mia vita
la mamma decise di organizzando un
matrimonio con un uomo più grande è
molto più grandi di me molto io in quel
momento non pensavo ad altro che
scappare come scappare ma sapevo come
fare altro che avevo soltanto quasi 16
anni
ed ecco qui che la mia passione mi è
venuto incontro
il mio allenatore mi fece il biglietto e
torna in italia e tornai a casa da papà
l'unico membro della famiglia rimasta in
italia e per tranquillizzare la sua ira
gli disse papà volevo sposarlo libico
visto che papa era di origine libica e
niente papa non se l'è bevuta per niente
la mamma l'aveva già informato di tutto
e lì sono iniziate tutti i problemi sono
gli stati problemi le minacce le
violenze i castighi non avevo più
libertà non potevo più fare nulla
niente scuola niente allenamenti niente
oratorio
figuriamoci uscire con gli amici
in quel periodo
non sapevo cosa fare sono stati cinque
giorni intensi per me
al ritorno della mamma potete immaginare
potete immaginare potuto accadere
il ritorno della mamma non aiutato per
niente anzi ha aumentato il tutto papa
non riusciva più a controllarsi da una
parte mi faceva pena perché comunque
quella è la sua cultura
mi faceva tenerezza perché non riuscivo
a fargli capire che io sono cresciuta in
italia non riuscivo
o meglio lui non capiva
in quel periodo dopo neanche un giorno
che ritorno dalla mamma non riuscivo più
a stare in quella casa non riuscivo più
a vivere in quella casa non avevo più in
diritto e le mie sorelle che guardavano
malissimo i miei genitori neanche mi
rivolgevano la parola ero la pecora nera
della famiglia avevo compiuto cioè e
scappare a rifiutare un matrimonio
combinato
per loro era un rifiuto alla famiglia
non ce la facevo più prese dalla
disperazione dal non saper cosa fare
perché io non ci stavo ok mi picchiavano
e tutto ma non ci stavo non le dicevo
che avete ragione no io non ci sto così
sono le cose e ovviamente dall'altra
parte c'era ritorno presa da un momento
di disperazione disperazione si tenta il
suicidio e andò in coma e anche qui è
stato proprio il mio allenatore a
salvarmi la vita
andai in coma alla fine ringrazia di me
la sono trovata con cinque giorni al mio
risveglio in ospedale apri gli occhi e
vi di questa luce fortissima fortissima
e mi domandai se stesse vedendo il
paradiso no lì è stato dare valore alla
vita ho iniziato a dare un valore
particolare alla vita perché comunque
non avevo così chiara la soluzione della
situazione
non avevo ben chiaro quello che mi
aspettava fuori dall'ospedale ma
credetemi aveva un'energia incredibile
energia che mi faceva sentire
invincibile eros tra super positiva in
quel momento ero solo che positiva la
mia famiglia non c'era più subito dopo
loro mi hanno disconosciuto dalla
famiglia ho iniziato da una parte a
sentirmi sola
sono stata portata in una comunità
protetta
e lì ho iniziato a capire che solo io
potevo prendere in mano la mia vita solo
io a 16 anni devo scegliere e capire
capire cosa è giusto e cosa era
sbagliato mi faceva paura tanta paura
dice economica faccia
ok mi perderò
per me è la comunità era oddio diventerò
una ragazza di comunità in cemento era
una drogata addirittura dicevo è invece
stato tutt'altro
riprendo a correre con tutta questa
situazione è l'unica cosa che mi dava
forze rari appoggiarmi a ciò che facevo
prima
come la corsa la scuola non è stato ad
allenarmi per me correre è come andare
dallo psicologo ti mette in contatto con
te stesso correrti costringe alla fine
ad ascoltarti perché sei lì sei tu che
corri per me correre è una cosa
interiore perché è come se fosse un
esame di coscienza involontario perché
alla fine sei tu che sceglie di prendere
andare a correre anche
se non vai a fare le gare i campionati
italiani mondiale però anche il fatto a
tutti è capitato di dire
arriva l'estate vada corre quindi
correre secondo me siamo noi che
scegliamo di prendere andare a correre
quindi siamo noi che decidiamo di farci
questo esame di coscienza
un giorno al campo sinti la frase che mi
ha cambiato la vita
senti un allenatore che spiegava un
ragazzo come si facevano gli ostacoli
correndo e gli dissi l'ostacolo non va
ha saltato tu non salti gli ostacoli gli
ostacoli vanno affrontati e superati
sono illuminata wow
la mia frase qualcuno da lassù ha
pensato a me e lì ho deciso di fare così
con la mia vita prendere i problemi
affrontarli e cercare di superarli
anche se credetemi davvero difficile
sono iniziate le difficoltà lì ho
iniziato a imparare a fidarmi di chi mi
allenava soprattutto imparare ad
affidarmi piano piano iniziato a
specializzarmi nei 400 ostacoli
quante cadute però grazie a dio mi son
sempre rialzata fino ad arrivare ai
campionati italiani
nel frattempo tutto questo è il mio
passaporto era scaduto e di conseguente
non potevo più rinnovarlo perché sono
stato discusso anche dallo stato di vico
non potendo più rinnovare il passaporto
non potevo più rinnovare il permesso di
soggiorno non potendo più rinnovare il
permesso di soggiorno non potevo stare
in italia non mi rimaneva altro che
richiedere asilo politico e non sono
venuto con il barcone nasa devi farlo
per me
richiesta di asilo politico mi ha
provocato tanta sofferenza stampa dopo
dieci anni in italia mi sentivo italiano
avevo lasciato tutto avevo non avete
perso tutta la famiglia tutto solo
perché da una parte che colpa ne avevo
io mi hanno portato loro in italia il
sentivo italiano ma non lo sia diceva
che non lo ero ma lui era un punto mi
sono aggrappata ciò che mi faceva che mi
rendeva felice alla corsa per iniziare
ad affrontare anche questo ostacolo
prima di ogni gara ho ancora paura ho
sempre paura ma io penso che la vita sia
come una gara hai paura affronti vai e
comunque vada ricordate che avete sempre
un'altra possibilità alle gare finisce
la gara non ho fatto il personale mi ha
fatto questa ma sai sempre che hai
sempre la possibilità di farne un'altra
di gara al lavoro va tutto male tu fai
sempre che ne hai un'altra di
possibilità
io penso che la vita sia lunga quindi
per questo che penso che dico sempre la
vita è come una gara questione poco
poche settimane fa avrei dovuto correre
a birmingham
presentando la mia società c'era nei
campionati europei di squadre e per
questioni burocratiche non chiare legate
al mio passaporto ha dimostato di
rifugiata politica mi hanno rifiutato il
visto
io ho sempre pensato che lo sport se osi
fatto per unire e non per dividere
e ancora oggi è ancora oggi dei pezzi di
carta mi definiscono senza che io possa
difendermi ho dire voglio solo correre
alla fine è quello che voglio fare
vengo privato senza capire il perché di
ciò che considero il mio diritto davvero
questa data che mi ha veramente creato
un problema interiore perché mi sentivo
discriminata
però penso che anche questo anche questo
sarà un ostacolo non facile da superare
ma l'energia che avevo quando apri gli
occhi e ancora qui presenti in presenti
ma perché mi dà una forza incredibile
per andare avanti
voi pensate quanti che sono fortunata
che io mi sento fortunata dopo tutto
quello che è passato si perchè comunque
23 anni ho imparato tantissimo dalla
vita a 23 hanno dovuto affrontare cose
che magari alcuni al 50 40 non ho ancora
avuto il modo di affrontare come spero
che non è di provare comunque a dare
valore a ciò che fa ogni giorno della
mia vita ogni giorno che mi sveglio io
dico che bella ecco un altro giorno
cerco di accordi cogliere ogni
possibilità che mi si pone davanti ciò
che ho vissuto mi ha reso veramente
ricca mi ha arricchito
sì quando sono con i miei compagni mi
sento diversa mi sento con qualcosa in
più quel qualcosa in più che mi permette
di dire anch'io la mia c'è conosciuto mi
ha insegnato quanto è importante
scegliere ciò che ci rende felice ogni
giorno della nostra vita e io nella mia
vita ho scelto ho scelto un futuro
basato sulla felicità e correre mi rende
molto felice
ne andrò avanti a farlo
[Applauso]
[Musica]